I told you earlier last week that Donald
Trump would be having a medical exam to
prove his fitness and stability and
maybe even his stable genius level
although he probably had no idea that
the test he was going half was not going
to prove whether or not he was a genius
I also told you last week that the exam
would prove absolutely nothing because
it's basically a physical exam with some
verbal questions again that relate to
physical health like the amount in
nature of trumps sexual activity or
whatever it's not one way or the other
going to prove or disprove humps Trump's
cognitive abilities and fitness to serve
as president the exam was scheduled for
last Friday and according to a note
released by the White House the exam
happened and it went just absolutely
incredibly well exactly as we predicted
the note from the White House would say
the problem is that the doctor's note
that Trump released might well be fake
why does it appear to be fake well the
doctor who supposedly wrote the note
miss Feld his own name the White House
doctor is Ronnie Jackson spelled ro and
and why here's a note from 2014 under
President Obama and you can see it's a
memo prepared for Jay Carney the
assistant to the President and White
House press secretary in June of 2014
and it is from Ronnie L Jackson ro n NY
MD F a a II M the note released by the
White House has this exact same doctor
spelling his name Ronnie ro n ie here is
a clip from the Rachel Maddow program on
MSNBC in this straight the White House
says this is what White House physician
rear admiral Ronnie Jackson said about
the president's physical today quote the
president's physical exam today at
Walter Reed National Military Medical
Center went exceptionally well the
president is in excellent health and I
look forward to briefing some of the
details on Tuesday right and then right
at the end of that statement from the
White House they put his name on it
dr. Ronnie Jackson
you know what I'm gonna go out on a limb
here and raise the possibility that this
statement was not written by the White
House physician Rear Admiral dr. Ronnie
Jackson and I'm not gonna say that
because of the assertions about how
exceptionally well the president's
physical went or how excellent his
health is I'm not basing my skepticism
about the authorship of this statement
on the Trump enos of the statement
itself I'm just setting that aside know
the reason I think this might not have
actually been written by the White House
physician dr. Ronnie Jackson is because
that is not how you spell Ronnie Jackson
either the White House physician today
suddenly lost the ability to correctly
spell his own name in which case he
shouldn't be anybody's doctor today let
alone the president's or alternatively
the White House put out the statement
today as if it was from him so there is
one other possibility which is that this
is a statement from Ronnie Jackson and
the statement was copy and pasted but
then someone typed in Ronnie Jackson and
they misspelled it or something like
that it's also weird because usually dr.
Ronnie Jackson spells his name
Ronnie Jackson MD not dr. Ronnie Jackson
I actually have a story about this I
once was about to hire someone on the
David Pakman show and they misspelled
their own name in the new hire paperwork
and I immediately rescinded the offer
and this was years ago and it might seem
kind of tougher haphazard but you know
attention to detail and writing are
really important at the David Pakman
show you know this by now Pat and if you
misspell your own name it's kind of over
the line for me and I rescinded the
offer and I said I'm sorry we're not
gonna be able to offer you employment
I've heard horror stories about someone
who said that they majored in pubic
policy right that's a real hypo right
yes Oh whisper your name but I think
that's a little bit more significant I
think it is I think it is and so as far
as the exam itself obviously as
predicted the exam exam census Trump is
super healthy and as I predicted it
tells us absolutely nothing about his
cognitive state it tells us nothing
about possible dementia related to
cognitive decline or cognitive decline
related to dementia rather no basic
information President Obama's exams
would always
wait hi Trump's weight is definitely a
problem if you've see ever seen a
picture of Donald Trump it says nothing
about which tests were performed it says
nothing about medications that Trump is
on so basically this exam not only did
it say nothing about Trump's mental
health which was sort of the point of
the exam it really didn't tell us
anything about Trump's physical health
anyway and that really gets me to the
point that I want to make and it again
has to do I know it's get becoming
broken record like it has to do with
cognitive dissonance and among trumpets
any reasonable person knows that this
test was never meant to be about his
actual physical or mental health it was
just a reaction by Trump to allegations
made about his cognitive decline it was
just getting something on the record to
show I'm fine right even the general
claim that this guy's in great health
isn't believable he's in his 70s he's
significantly overweight he does know
exercise he eats a ton of fast food
there's no way that this is a very
healthy physically healthy individual
and what we then get to is the claim
that even if his physical health were
good were supposed to take this exam as
proof that he has no cognitive decline
which again was never even the point of
the test to begin with and hasn't even
been addressed the trumpets don't know
what to do they don't know what to do
and remember that with no evidence Trump
claimed that President Obama wasn't
really from the United States and
released a fake birth certificate and a
huge contingent of the people that
became Trump astaidhu I believe Trump I
believe Trump even though we have no
evidence for the birtherism and now when
we have real reasons to be concerned
about Trump's cognitive state he
releases this bogus note and the
trumpets seem completely unworried and
certainly the trumpets won't be swayed
by this but I think I have to hear this
straight from the horse's mouth right
let's see what Ronnie Jackson has to say
about it I hope so on the one hand he
could say I don't want to be embroiled
in some political battle not even on the
other he's a professional he's a doctor
and he doesn't want his notes to be
faked and forged I don't think it's
either because he simply cannot disclose
anything due to HIPAA laws it's up to
Trump to release it he can
not comment unless I guess Trump signed
off and said you're allowed to go speak
in the media about my health and I bet
they knew that all along yes of course
they did and that's why exactly I said
last week we will only hear what Trump
wants us to hear let's take a break
join our subreddit at david pakman.com
slash read it today's episode is
sponsored in part by endo Chino which
makes made-to-measure suits and I love
my endo Chino suit in fact I've worn it
to a bunch of weddings over the summer
and everybody who sees it on me for the
first time says that's a really nicely
fitting suit where did you buy that and
I say hey listen there's nothing better
than made-to-measure I went to one of
the nearly 10 storefronts that indogene
o has one of them is here in Boston and
I worked with Chris he measured me and I
got a custom-made suit but if you don't
live near an endo Chino location you can
go online you pick your fabrics you pick
your customizations you submit your
measurements the website tells you what
to measure and how and then you get a
custom-made suit in the mail in three
weeks or less and you can shop at Indo
Chino comm and this week david pakman
show viewers and listeners can get any
premium Indo Chino suit for just 359 at
Indo Chino comm when you enter the code
Pakman at checkout that's over 50% off
the regular price for a premium
made-to-measure suit plus shipping is
free one more time that's Indo Chino
dot-com promo code hackman for any
premium suit for 359 with free shipping